e aí
eu sou uma ativista da equidade de
gênero
bom e como todas as mulheres ativistas
da equidade de gênero nós repetimos como
se fosse um mantra que mais mulheres em
todas as instâncias de poder criam um
ambiente mais inovador trazem mais
lucratividade quando falamos do setor
privado e quando na esfera pública elas
transformam a sociedade ao seu redor
como tudo
e no entanto fica uma pergunta
e onde estão as mulheres negras quando
falamos de liderança feminina
e nós estamos sobrevivendo
me sinto em falar que nós ainda estamos
sobrevivendo como se tivéssemos vindo
ainda nos navios negreiros
nós somos 61 por cento das vítimas de
feminicídio
nós somos 50,9 por cento das vítimas de
violência sexual
e quando não nos matam
a mata os seus filhos
nós correspondemos a 63 pontos sete
porcento dos desempregados do nosso país
é uma mulher negra ganhar menos da
metade do que um homem branco na mesma
posição informação
é isso resultado do racismo estrutural e
institucional que nos atinge desde 1500
e onde nós estamos
nós estamos aqui todo dia servindo de
base para que a sociedade brasileira
vence para que todas as mulheres possam
avançar
é só estarmos e 0,4 por cento dos cargos
executivos
é porque o que justifica 28 por cento da
população brasileira é somos 60 milhões
não somos poucas somos muitas é
nós correspondemos a 16 por cento de
tudo que é consumido nesse país existe
um estudo que fala que as mulheres
negras circulam na economia 704b
imaginem se estivéssemos falando de
igualdade salarial o quanto movimentar
íamos na economia eu sandália se
sobrevive
em sair da bahia
o convite reais e duas filhas para a
cidade maravilhosa
a curva uma curta longa história eu
resolvi vender salgado tinha como foco a
sobrevivência quando os filhos contas
para pagar precisava de dinheiro
carteira e transporte e continuar
procurando emprego vende salgado no trem
que sai do bairro da posse na baixada
fluminense até a central saía vendendo
com duas bolsas do trem e chegava até o
méier palavra e continuava vender
e até que tive a primeira oportunidade
e foi a primeira oportunidade que
agarrei como uma naufraga que me trouxe
até aqui
com todos os avanços que fiz ao longo da
minha história e carreira pessoal foram
possíveis porque resgatei junto a mim ou
sexualidade o poder das irmandades e das
redes de mulheres conseguir avançar
porque junto com mulheres fantásticas
conseguir apoio suficiente para poder
continuar estudando continuar
trabalhando com duas filhas e ganhando
menos
e não foi fácil chegar até aqui mas não
se enganem a minha história ela não é
para servir de base para o discurso de
meritocracia
eu não quero ser protagonista ou a única
nos espaços onde estou esse tipo de
protagonismo definitivamente não me
interessa
e eu quero que sejamos muitas
a ser a única não é nenhum mérito apenas
mostra a distância que separa
é uma mulher negra de uma mulher branca
e a nossa linha de partida diferente
é por isso que é preciso contar as
nossas histórias a minha história não é
diferente de nenhuma de outras mulheres
periféricas dos países não é diferente
da história das minhas astrais que
conseguiram mudar a história de suas
famílias e de seus filhos vendendo pelos
tabuleiros na rua das ruas da bahia
e não há nada de diferente
e se para uma mulher branca
a alcançar um posto de liderança é
quebrar o teto de vidro
e para uma mulher negra esse teto de
vidro é blindado
eu ia acreditando nessa força do
feminino essa força do inclusão que eu
convido vocês a fazerem parte desse
movimento que seja real e que seja
verdadeiro
e não há como justificar a exclusão de
quem movimenta uma sociedade que se viu
de base para o avanço das mulheres
brancas servindo como babá como
empregada doméstica e se não é mais o
nosso lugar apenas o nosso lugar
e nós merecemos está em qualquer posição
o d-fine questionam como você conseguiu
mas ninguém pergunta como você chegou
até aqui
e nem tudo que eu passei até chegar até
aqui
e em reuniões desqualificam a minha fala
já foi chamada de macaca na rua
é mas eu fui treinada para seguir firme
e seguir adiante apesar de
e tem romantismos
e nessa fala
é mas apesar de eu continuo seguindo
é muito mais inspirada
e pelas que vieram antes de mim
e pelas que virão
o e fortalecida mais do que nunca pela
minha a socialidade eu não ando só
é o que eu peço e convido a todos vocês
é que nós podemos mudar essa história
nós cada um cada um devido é que vai
fazer a diferença não há como falar de
inovação nas organizações progresso
econômico se a gente continua com esses
patamares de desigualdade
e nós vamos avançar não iremos avançar
como sociedade nem tão pouco como seres
humanos
e esse movimento é de todas e de todos
ah eu convido aqueles que já estão
conosco na causa por convicção mas
também aos que aderiram de forma
conveniente aliás pretinha tá na moda
nosso cabelo tá na moda nosso cabelo da
lucro ultimamente
e a luz acompanhar nesse processo de
mudança e de transformação
e eu acredito demais eu sou um otimista
eu acredito no poder da abundância
feminina e eu sei que as mulheres são
serão as catalisadoras dessa
transformação sem excluir ninguém sem
deixar ninguém para trás trazendo os
homens para perto
é porque essa mudança ela vai acontecer
queiram não como uma grande enchente de
rio que chega de forma forte e
silenciosa e modifica tudo por onde
passa
e nada mais será como antes
e a representatividade importa
e aí